spectator TV is picking up thousands of
new subscribers every week and you
should be one of them just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode
[Music]
from next year Canada will expand as
assisted death laws so people with
mental illnesses can choose to end their
own lives in a spectator column this
week Douglas Murray wonders what lovely
liberal Canada is doing he joins me now
Douglas thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um you arrived in the magazine this week
about how Canada is expanding its
assisted dying laws in what sounds like
a pretty horrific way uh can you tell us
about it please
yes I mean long-term readers of the
magazine will know I've written about
this in the magazine before there's an
incredibly complex uh and intense debate
about assisted dying and there are good
arguments on all sides
um but one of the points that I have
made repeatedly in the magazine in about
different countries in recent years is
the necessity of making sure that if you
are talking about assisted dying for the
uh the terminally ill who can have
nothing done to help them effectively a
sort of slightly earlier palliative care
um you've got to be extremely careful
that this doesn't expand and I wrote
some years ago having spoken to doctors
who did euthanasia in the Netherlands
and Belgium the the old slippery slope
argument we hear about and people
usually use as a dismissal they say oh
you're getting all slippery slope on us
I said well here is an ethical question
where the slope is really slippery uh it
was in Belgium again last year I wrote
about the case of the young woman who
was
um was killed by the state allowed to
die by the state phrase it as you will
because she had PTSD from surviving the
Brussels Airport attack in 2016 where
she saw many of her classmates she was
17 at the time blown up in front of her
the Belgian stage is far too civilized
of course to execute any of the men
involved in the Brussels Airport attack
but it did manage to put down one of the
victims of the attack because now being
chalked up as another victim this time
it's Canada that is that is on this
slope and gosh is it slippery in 2016 uh
the lovely liberal Canadian government
introduced what it called the medical
assistance in dying or made act and
again as in so many other Western
countries it was meant to be only for
people with terminal illness and that's
how it got through but through as if
it's incredibly strict
two years ago the Canadian government
expanded the law and two years ago it
was allowed to Encompass people who had
non-terminal conditions
so you can see where this is going
as of March next year this is going to
be expanded again and it will be allowed
to include medically assisted dying for
people whose sole underlying condition
is mental illness
now I suggest that anyone who isn't at
this point ethically concerned isn't
thinking deeply about this
and there's a specific case you
mentioned as well Douglas I think it's
Lisa poorly can you can you tell her a
bit about tell us a bit about her
yes she gave an interview recently she's
one of a number of people who've said
you know that they're sort of looking
forward to next march the Canadian
government itself presents uh the
development of the new law as if it's a
sort of wonderful exciting new
opportunity for the Canadian public it
it's pretty dystopian if you think about
it like that a woman called Lisa pawley
is one of those who seems to be viewing
it in that light she's a 47 year old
woman and she's suffered from anorexia
uh for most of her life she's had you
know it's very debilitating eating
disorder and unfortunately for her
um unlike many young women who have it
she hasn't been able to shake it off
um she hasn't been able to get rid of it
she currently weighs I think six Stone
six pounds uh she uh is too weak to
carry groceries back from the shop she
says every day is Hell I'm so tired I'm
done I've tried everything I feel like
I've lived my life uh it was the quote
she gave and as I say in the piece of 47
year old who feels that they've lived
their life is a 47 year old in need of
help and I would submit that anorexia
which is an incredibly debilitating
condition as anyone knows who's either
had it themselves I had a family member
or a loved one who's had it knows that
it requires very very intense help love
support and much more
but the message given off by a society
that says actually we've got a cure for
anorexia it's medical assistance in
dying is a society that gives out one of
the worst messages possible to the
predominantly young women who suffer
from that condition
and like I say I think it would be
rightfully seen as abhorrent if you told
someone with anorexia that they showed
or they're right to think that they
should kill themselves but Canada seems
to be sort of sleep walking towards this
I mean you mentioned in your in your
first answer the fact that this is a
very liberal soft cuddly government do
you think that's linked to the fact that
they've just sort of lost their moral
compass on this
oh absolutely and you know to do
something truly atrocious you have to
wrap it up these days in the language of
compassion you can do almost anything
get away with almost anything in a
modern society if you talk about an
incompassionate term I give the example
at the beginning of the piece I open the
piece by talking about Martin amos's
1991 Masterpiece times Arrow it's it's a
novel where everything goes backwards
time goes backwards everything happens
in Reverse
um every daily action and uh it includes
as part of its its its narrative is the
Holocaust in reverse and I say is this
very it's very hard to say anything new
about the Holocaust but Martha name is
manage it'll have any new light on it
Martin's name is managers actually in
that novel
um when towards what is the end of the
Holocaust in the reverse which is of
course the beginning of the Holocaust as
it happened uh the bodies that they take
out of the oven and bring into life one
of the people who works in the the
Crematory it starts to worry that the
bodies that they're taking out of the
oven seem to be increasingly deformed
and the character in The Amos novel
starts to wonder whether it's worth
bringing these people to life at all
which is of course a reference to that
way in which and I'm not using the
Holocaust to say what Canada is doing is
about to lead to the murder of millions
of Jews or anything like that I'm saying
that it's a reminder of the fact that
such great atrocities from history can
start with things that people can nod
along in the name of compassion a lot of
eugenics went this way started this way
um a medically assisted eye assistance
to people with debilitating conditions
and much more the mentally ill and I say
that there's a particular corner of this
and I've pointed this out in the
magazine before I pointed this out when
Britain was considering new laws on this
much of the problem of this is the
Illusion in our day
uh between medical illness and mental
illness physical illness and mental
illness huge amount of work has been
done and again you might be in favor of
this or against it but huge amount of
work has been done by government by the
NHS by celebrities even Royals to talk
about the way in which medical the way
in which
mental illness should be regarded as
being on a par with physical illness
once you get onto euthanasia medically
assisted diet as they call it again in
Canada made
once you get onto that and you say
mental ill you have a society that says
mental illness and physical illness are
on a par then you allow people to find a
way on the state to be killed
effectively assisted to die because they
have a mental illness I give the example
in the piece this has already come up
this is not a um this is not a dystopian
uh fear-mongering last year a member of
the Canadian Armed Forces a veteran
called this veterans uh Veterans Affairs
Canada which is sort of veterans support
Association he was suffering from PTSD
so bear it in mind this is a this is a a
young man who had been sent to War by
his country had presumably seen some of
the things you see in war war is always
unpleasant always uh traumatizing to
some extent to the people who
participate in it this man had been sent
out by his country he's now returned he
should be getting the best possible care
as all veterans should be when he called
Veterans Affairs Canada unprompted he it
was suggested by the person he spoke
with that perhaps he should try
euthanasia
now
PTSD is especially for it's been a
somewhat over diagnosed in recent years
but PTSD for soldiers uh the veterans is
a very serious thing which needs very
serious again love care compassion and
treatment the idea that you would as a
society say we will send our soldiers
out to fight and kill and potentially
die for the country and if they find it
all too traumatic once they get home we
can kill them
this is not a dystopia this is already
started and all in the name of
compassion societies that do this will
among other things become far less
Justice the Netherlands and Belgium are
far less developed in palliative care
than Britain is and the doctors involved
for told me this because they have
euthanasia in those countries so a
country like Canada that believes that
that that medically assisted dying
euthanasia is a good response to trauma
to anorexia and much more will be a
society that that is less good at
treating people with those conditions in
the way in which they should be treated
because they will be offering death as
one of the options on the board of
treatments and you mentioned the piece
as well that you know and and as you're
saying then it takes a lot of effort and
a lot of States capacity to sort of help
some with mental illness whilst
euthanasia is almost the cheap easy
option do you get the sentences of
almost like a
a financial incentive to push people
towards euthanasia now
well I don't know if there is at the
moment but there could well be at some
point one of the the moral issues that
has often come up with euthanasia even
for people with medical conditions that
are terminal is can we be sure that
loved ones aren't encouraging them to
this effectively to get a cash Bonanza
it seems unimaginable that anyone would
but human nature being what it is of
course some people will so there has
always been this kind of fear even with
the most clear-cut case that people in
favor of euthanasia can present which is
people with terminal illnesses uh who
are close to the to the end anyway
um of course uh it's it's not just
possible but likely the financial
incentives will start to step into this
they always do
um the Canadian government has had such
extraordinary overreach in recent years
in things like again as I've written
about before in the magazine the closure
of bank accounts of people who are
critics of it at home the um Corruption
of the Canadian media all these things
have been done in the name of compassion
and much more the Canadian government is
already pretty corrupted actually among
Western governments uh um and uh it
seems to be able to get away Trudeau
himself seems to be able to get away
with almost anything because he does it
in this dippy
um sort of floppy-haired floppish
language of compassion and love while
showing very little Compassion or love
for the people of his country and in
fact a sort of disdain for the average
person I have absolutely no faith in the
Canadian government to be fair in its
treatment of its citizenry if they have
any views that the Canadian government
doesn't disagree with the idea that the
choice of life or death could be in the
hands of the Canadian government gives
me the shudders again then this is a
government that believes it is too
Superior too morally pure to ever think
of executing for somebody for a cry such
as mass murder child rape or anything
else far too morally Superior like
Britain like all the EU countries we
think we've got beyond that we've got
Beyond public execution we've got Beyond
private executions executions in prisons
of prisoners with two two we're past
that we've developed
but we are or Canada is a society
able to allow and encourage indeed
people with
mental conditions like anorexia I PTSD
to be effectively killed by the state I
don't think the state has that right
anywhere I I cannot see how a country
posing as a liberal democracy can go
down this route without criticism and
and finally Douglas I wonder what you
think about the lessons for Britain here
I mean as I say there's been a
long-running campaign for euthanasia in
the case of terminal illnesses do you
think it's possible to have that and
stop there or do you think once that
sort of Rubicon has been crossed of the
state taking a life then you're sort of
opening yourself up for a world of
Horrors
well I've had this argument on The
Spectator podcast before not least with
with Lord Faulkner who was one of the
people uh pushing the assisted dying act
in the House of Lords
um he was one of those who again he it's
all oh Douglas is getting all slippery
slope on us
um if I was Lord falcon or one of the
people in that campaign in the UK and I
know and have spoken with people
involved in that I respect the opinions
of some of them very very much but if I
were them I would look at what was
happening in Canada and think those
Canadians have mucked up our whole case
you know the whole way in which the the
assisted dying in Britain act would come
in would be if it was incredibly
carefully defined and Incredibly
carefully policed and it is already
clear in my view from the Netherlands
and Belgium which are not far away from
us as Societies in any uh ethical or
geographical sense it's already clear
from there how slippery this slope is
and where Lord Falcon and others say I
was is getting all slippery slope on us
now I would say again look at Canada
look at what you can do in Canada now in
the name of compassion look at the
Canadian government's websites the way
in which it presents next march as being
this wonderful new opportunity for
Canadians this really is something
atrocious happening in our own time and
as the editor of spectator phrase and
Nelson has said to me a number of times
I often quote it instead of just
wrecking through the past and looking at
what other people did and how
astonishingly awful it was also think of
what is happening in your own time that
our successors might think is equally
awful and look at in an equally
despising light try to work out what
they are now and try to stop them early
I would suggest that when it comes to
medically assisted dying in the west and
the slippery slope in these Ultra
liberal democracies it is just such a
case thank you very much Douglas unlock
unlimited access to the spectator
magazine for free for one month and then
pay just one pound a week after that go
to spectator.co.uk forward slash best to
subscribe today
[Music]
thank you
foreign